ralph for a long time there's been
speculation as to whether or not you're
gay
yesterday a very interesting development
here at the show you go ahead doug
i had a question for ronnie if ralph
admits to being gay
would ronnie admit to who he was voting
for there's a
good one there's a challenge throw down
that challenge
ronnie it's your 71st birthday and happy
birthday
birthday all 71 years have led to this
moment it might be the greatest moment
in show history i'm putting way more on
the line than ronnie is
i want ronnie to just say who he's
voting for dude i really don't care if
you're gay or not it doesn't matter to
me i don't care
just like i want to do what i want robin
you can roll your head around all you
want i don't care
now it's time it's 9 20 in the morning
i'm gonna ask you now
all of the fans are listening all you
gotta do is say who you're voting for i
know you don't want to
i know it's something you don't want to
talk about i get it
but if you should consider saying who
you're voting for
then we can quiz ralph what's it gonna
be
it's time for the answer drum roll
please i discussed it with stephanie
last night
and uh i'm pretty much sticking to what
i
my guns uh we don't
neither one of us care about whether
ralph is gay or not
and it shouldn't be my decision whether
he should come out of the closet by
saying who i'm voting for that's
nobody's business
and that's the way it's going to be
what
[Laughter]
wait can you repeat that i didn't hear
it i i think the zoom
blanked out no no it didn't blank out
ronnie this is the biggest
buzzkill ever yeah and i knew he was
gonna deliver it i knew i'm sorry man
but uh man that's that's wow that's my
that's my stand he's standing in all the
wrong places
why not stand what a [ __ ] stand
this is a slam [ __ ] dunk literally
nobody cares who you're voting for we
all just want to get the ralph
the fire's gone from ronnie's belly he's
achieved
the apex of his fame so kind of [ __ ] you
howard you know
is this more about principle now it's
principal dude
okay what happened
because you didn't have it in 2016. when
did this principle
show up last week apparently
ronnie i can't even tell you how
important it is to me
as a human being to know this because
i've been friends with this guy a long
time
you should know that about a best friend
right and i swear yes and i swear to you
ralph
you will always be my friend of course i
wouldn't doubt that
ronnie this is the greatest unanswered
question of my life
i know that it doesn't matter to you i
get it i'm saying is there any way you
can see yourself clear
to end this [ __ ] nightmare in my life
i've never begged for anything in
decades of radio i've
kept my cool i'm gonna hurt you
ronnie ronnie i've never been on my
knees in front of another man before
we want to know if ralph has i'm no
spring chicken it hurts down here
i know oh my god hold on one second
everyone
honey can you help me up
you know who batman is you ever hear of
him batman yeah yeah
sometimes gotham city couldn't be saved
there was only one guy who could save it
it was batman you're my batman right now
and batman always answers the call you
know eminem once wrote
lose yourself in the moment you own it
you better never let it go you only get
one
shot do not miss your chance to blow
this opportunity that comes
once in a lifetime this moment defines
who a man is
lose yourself in the moment you own it
you better never let it go
you only get one shot don't miss your
chance to blow this opportunity comes
once in a lifetime
my wife last night she says to me don't
worry about it ronnie will come through
she's going to come running down here
because she's got a million questions
for ralph
what if beth came down and made a politi
i'll text her
i'm going to ask that to come down in
fact
i'm going to do it i'm going to do it
i'm going to try everything i'm telling
you
i'm going to try i'm going to try and
tell you i don't know if she'll come
down
i just want you to hear what she had to
say let me text her please come on the
show
i'm texting her right now not to yeah
she'll listen to you
you need to hear from her i told her
don't do it with 19
news at the end of it
i need your help oh no is this bad it is
bad
weren't you so excited about this
explain to ronnie why this means so much
to us
ronnie this is the moment this is
it this is show history right now i
don't i don't like this card
what's going on how about the night that
you and i met
and you turned to me that night and go
oh your gay friend my new best friend my
new game is not gay
my friend is straight and then you said
no no no honey he's gay
okay ronnie let's do this who's that in
the middle
what is that
by the way you know who i'm voting for
right now oh that's cleavage
titties
[Music]
ronnie just say who you're voting for
please for us
all and then ralph will take over i'm
begging
no we still love you ronnie but i'm
terribly disappointed
there's a terminally ill child on the
phone who wants to ask
please i need to know if ralph touched
the teepee
the doctors say i will flash through the
knife
there's a child who won't last through
the night katie
poor child you're laughing at a
terminally ill child jd
wow the show is now officially over
we're in overtime
it hurts i've always been under the
delusion ronnie would do anything
and i'm wrong i'm wrong okay so i gotta
get over it
ronnie i love you you don't have to
worry pal you're still my buddy and you
need me
you call on me i'm always gonna be there
for you
you got a friend in me
you got a friend in me
you got troubles and i got em too
there isn't anything i wouldn't do for
you we stick together and we see it
through
cause you got a friend in me
and yeah you asked stephanie and she
says
no i thought rose
before the girls but i was wrong
i better go beat my boyfriend i will
talk to you later
see you soon goodbye sincerely once you
lay your
life down benji the show's over the
benji the show is over
benji you don't have a friend in me
benji you don't have a friend in me
all right everyone's my friend goodbye
everyone have a wonderful weekend
and we'll see you next time
[Music]